the teasers fascism promised a
light-hearted laugh filled adventure and
had everyone hoping the film could bring
some brightness to the mostly gloomy DC
extended universe now the reviews for
Shazam are officially in and we finally
know whether the film sword or sank
spoiler alert
with a 92% fresh score on Rotten
Tomatoes as of the making of this video
it's pretty clear that Warner Brothers
managed to capture some real magic this
time around let's dive in and see what
the critics had to say too many films
seem to forget that people up and go to
the movies because they want to have fun
well thank goodness fishes am because
critics agree that the movie has plenty
of fun and then some screen crashes
Motsinger said it's an escape from your
troubles you feel good when it's over
and Forbes contributor Mark Hughes said
the film is such a feel-good
family-friendly joyously exciting and
amusing production people will keep
recommending it to their friends and
loved ones and many were returned for
second and maybe even third viewings
comingsoon.net Alan Kearney meanwhile
compared Shazam to a warm happy puppy
Shazam invites everyone to have a good
time it doesn't have a mean-spirited
bone in his body
Shazam has a big goofy smile on its face
and you can't help but smile back this
is a puppy dog of a movie and Beatrice
for joven of the wrap said Shazam is
such an unexpected joy from start to
finish at a time when Hollywood is
choking to death on all the superhero
films our Studios keep ramming down its
roads here comes one that looks at the
genre in a different light and REE
conceives it on a human level I'd like
to purchase some of your finest beer
please
[Music]
speaking of that human-level the movie
isn't just fun it's also surprisingly
moving thanks to a story that's as much
about billy batson search for belonging
as it is super heroics Alex about
santosa folks wrote that the film
understands the humor and comedy are
ways to approach sensitive ideas like
children talking about feeling and
wanted after being abandoned by their
parents or what it's like to live with a
disability he added humanity is what
Shazam is fluent in and if we're lucky
she's Amish shows us we can share a
little bit of that magic our magic with
others at the heart of the film are
three great performances our critics are
universally praising Zachary Levi as the
big red cheese asher angel as his
younger alter ego Billy Batson and Jack
Dylan grazer as Billy's new foster
brother Freddie Freeman The Hollywood
Reporter's Frank Scheck wrote leave via
satellite in the central role
hilariously conveying the goofy
adolescent within the strapping body of
his muscle-bound superhero variety
critic Owen gleiberman agreed saying
Zachary Levi brings off something so
winning its irresistible he uses that
innocent quality to take the superhero
stuffing out of the material and to let
Shazam discover his identity in a way
that makes this the freshest origin
story in some time as IGN's Jimbo Vader
said Zachary Levi was born to play the
super-powered man-child as for the rest
of the young cast The Associated Press's
Lindsey Barr wrote the young actors
assembled here are astounding and
immediately captivating especially
grazier as Freddie crazier and Levi a
perfectly matched for the job and
grazier is beyond his years with his
ability to draw a laugh
Frank's Scheck of The Hollywood Reporter
agreed that the chemistry of the cast
made the film right saying angel and
grazer worked together beautifully as
the teenage boys bonding over their joy
at discovering chasms powers I'm right
here you can't see me we're leading into
the film one area of concern for fans
was director David F Samberg who made
his name not in comedy or superhero
films but rather with the horror movies
light sails and Annabel creation so
would he be able to pull off such a
drastic shift in tone for Shazam
according to critics the answer is yes
Bob's
ribbit sir Mark Hughes sums up the
critical consensus saying director David
F Samberg delivered a near-perfect
distillation of everything a chasm movie
should be with the precise nuances and
aesthetics and performances to achieve
the tone and style the film needed in
order to succeed it cannot praise enough
to performances he got from his cast and
his overall ability to make such a
relatively smaller scale personal films
still feel big a bold and epic of course
nothing can be perfect and while critics
are mostly happy with Shazam there are a
couple things about the film they feel
could have been done better like for
instance there could have been less of a
frank check at the Hollywood Reporter
wrote what should have been a fun
fast-paced 105 minutes or so is dragged
out to a but numbing 132 and Digital Spy
critic Hugh Armitage felt similarly
saying the finale drags on longer than
it needs to
but Shazam is so much fun that's a minor
complaint the other focus of complaints
as a villain dr. sivana played by Mark
Strong what most critics felt strong
that the best he could with what he was
given to work with it seems he wasn't
given much Lindsay Barra The Associated
Press wrote
dr. sivana is woefully underwritten
although strong does his best being the
straight serious guy for the most part
it comes across as less of a threat and
more of a buzzkill that gets in the way
of all the fun we were having with
Freddie and Shazam fans and critics
alike seemed thrilled of the idea that
Shazam could usher in a fun new era of
lighter movies in the previously dire DC
extended universe fandango managing
editor eric davis wrote in his early
reaction to Shezan that it's unlike
anything DC as done before and Digital
spy's Hugh Armitage agreed as saying
Aquaman hinted a bold new approach to DC
movies that doesn't try to emulate the
MCU successors Shazam makes good on that
promise waving goodbye to the grim face
about flickers leaving us excited about
what they'll do next the future looks
bright how brights Mark Hughes of Forbes
wrote one of the best DC superhero
origin films ever made
Shazam is also one of the best and most
fun superhero films from any company
that sounds like true magic check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]